can you get two bugs i don't know i'm
actually really happy to watch this
video i think it's an interesting topic
so let's check it out well i think
there's some people that are fat and
they love it but that's not who they are
yeah i think their body you shouldn't be
proud of being that overweight
damn
all right it should be interesting
okay so they're bodybuilders
[Music]
how do you not know that is that a joke
a bad joke if it is hot take there's
such a thing as being too jacked i
strongly disagree
strongly here
didn't the man whose name i can't say
without getting demonetized say that the
same thing that people are getting too
big these days i don't know enough about
bodybuilding to tell bodybuilders if it
is but i think personally aesthetically
yeah absolutely you can never be too big
man
you can never be too big
you definitely can i am big compared to
what i used to be but not enough to what
i want to be yeah you're going to want
more you'll never be so awesome
right now never you'll never be
satisfied you'll never be satisfied this
is something i hear you hear a lot with
the bodybuilders of like they always
want more and more games yeah
everyone's saying like this is a bad
thing
imagine if you were just perfectly
content with everything how boring life
would be
am i the only one who thinks this you
know to always have a drive for
something that's a positive thing if you
ask me but yeah obviously it can become
toxic but you didn't take it to an
extreme like the people that injected
their arms with like synthol yes
bicep busted open like crazy things like
that i agree with that i agree with well
people do it on all kinds of body parts
okay people inject all kinds of things
okay it's not that weird
they all disagree
of course
but as far as other bodybuilders i can't
speak for them i've never dated a
bodybuilder so i have never seen the
goods of a male bodybuilder then how do
you know
then how do you know huh
little penis energy like when you see
guys and like the flashy cars all the
designer clothes and all that you're
like what are you compensating for dude
that's true yeah
yeah
everyone has a small penis
you drive a big car
so tiny it is no i just find it very
useful thank you okay
oh you have designer clothes you must
have a super tiny hate it uh no i just
prefer higher quality high-end fashion
smart beanies everyone is small paydays
girls be like don't judge my body
i need peepee so small
it's so small yeti
i have bought this morphe and don't
comment about me my body please be
sensitive oh your baby's so smart
sorry a bit of weird tangent what what
the the pace of this video is so off
what is happening all right here we go
here's the actual
episode people who are out of shape i
will go in the middle two
one go i think yeah i wouldn't move
because i i generally don't care i guess
if it depends how you praise the
question i'm just indifferent so i
assume that's in the middle i mean
people know when they're out of shape
they don't need to be told they need to
be loved and nurtured to do the right
things i agree with that
absolutely there's always so much shame
uh associated with uh being out of shape
and i don't think that's an effective
method to inspire people bullying in
high school i was 190 pound freshman
unless you're joseph apparently sorry he
was speaking english i moved here as an
immigrant i didn't like how i looked you
know i was made fun of some pe and that
was up to me to change that so you can
do it you're just choosing not to it so
yeah
they don't challenge themselves they
don't try those are the ones that you're
like
oh
i'm upset with you kinda yeah if i see
someone that's just playing video games
all day eating potato chips and not
doing anything else in their life i'm
like alright you know you could be doing
something else for your health we all
should be productive in a certain type
of way
but
no no i disagree productivity is such a
subjective thing it doesn't really
matter at the end of the day
what does it mean i think it's one thing
to do with a certain thing and then
complain about why that's what changes
it but hey you just want to send eat it
all day
that's all you mean
you make those little steps you walk
every day you change your diet you lift
more i wouldn't want to be discouraging
to those people because not at all not
discouraging motivating them you know
like i would want them to do something
good for themselves you know obviously
yeah
you should not be proud to be back oh
uh no
why would you
hey look mom i got diabetes
son that's awesome i'm so proud of you
like what
oh she's thinking about it she's like
maybe no that's the wrong opinion i'm
sorry
what
[Laughter]
i mean
when people hear the word fat it has
such a negative connotation to it when
like
why that's deep that's some deep why
well you know heart disease early
shorter life span
less accessibility
less freedom
all these other related diseases
that's generally you know the
association i think i think here's
here's the thing people are kind of
toxic in general against people that are
overweight and i think now people are
trying to com combat that by being like
no it's okay and then it's a it's great
to be fat actually but it's
you know the answer is probably
somewhere in the middle right we don't
do we really need this this to
compensate for this can't we just like
say okay you know what everyone should
like themselves and who they are and
whatever be proud of yourself sure but
that does not mean you should be proud
to be fat and that does not mean
people should hate you for being fat
right
bad thing like being unhealthy is a bad
thing but there's a lot of pride that is
unhealthy the same yeah it's the same
thing
yeah
you didn't listen to the question
clearly
being accepting of yourself as fat and
being proud to be fat you should love
yourself in all forms but you shouldn't
be proud of being that overweight and
unhealthy and it's not going to be proud
yeah it's not it's really not why not
like i said before hey mom i got
diabetes
why not be proud of it yeah
you did it you did it you
what
what what are you on about
you're just trying to be positive and it
doesn't know it's not that's toxic
positivity if you ask me it's something
to accept and love yourself for and not
beat on yourself for i think you can be
proud of it there's some people that are
fat or overweight and they love it but
that's probably who they are that's yeah
that's proud to be with yeah god damn
you did not listen
i have considered steroids next question
three
two
one
dark side i go i know i'm ready for this
one
it's important to be healthy at all
costs
shame on these fat people also i do
steroids
certain is one of those topics i feel
like i don't know enough about so i
don't want to you know make leaps of
judgment i know there are side effects
and obviously if you take it in a
moderate amount i think it's a different
thing and personally
i'm against it i think
it's not necessarily you know they're
bodybuilders but i think they're put in
a different category than me or anyone
probably watching this video their job
is to sort of thrive as much as possible
so i can't really judge bodybuilders for
taking steroids at all to be fair um but
i do think uh
like the the buff guy was like saying oh
what if people fat people influence are
the kids to be fat too like bodybuilders
are kind of doing the same thing i i
think the steroids is a topic that isn't
talked about that much it's kind of a
taboo subject people like to pretend
that they they're not on steroids when
they really are so they're boasting this
sort of unattainable or very difficult
at the very least level of
muscularity or body type to people that
maybe unbe don't know enough about it
you know they look at themselves they
compare and you know you feel [ __ ] about
it and boohoo i guess you could say to
that but you know
you i've heard of my uh upbringing you
know about how females have an
unattainable standard in their weight
you know
girls are getting thinner and thinner
and thinner and it's getting really
unhealthy and you know they even
photoshop images to the point that it's
unhealthy well we kind of have the same
thing i mean obviously both boys and
girls can work out but general you know
you see really buff dudes they are on
steroids a lot of people don't know that
they're on steroids kind of the same
thing really i wish it was some more
talked about things at least people know
it's the same thing in in movies you
know you look at actors they know they
have that shot where they're gonna be
shirtless or muscular you know and they
gain a ton of weight in super short
amount of time like obviously they've
done uh steroids to achieve that how is
that not the same thing uh i'm willing
to admit that i might have the wrong
opinion here because i don't know enough
about it and i you know i've never taken
steroids i don't know what it's like i
will never do it anyway because i think
in general you need steroids obviously
to maintain the musc uh the bill that
you have like if you stop taking it you
lose the muscles obviously it's easier
to regain muscles that you've already
built
so on that perspective i can understand
it but i just personally in my personal
philosophy is just that i wouldn't want
to take something that would make me
dependent on something to be at a
certain state it's kind of like how
people
take sort of drugs to receive some sort
of enlightenment you know you're
depending on the drugs to achieve a
certain thing it kind of removes the
whole point from me plus i don't
generally care of being that big anyway
plus i'm i'm not and near even near
anyway
but kind of the same way as people being
overweight and same people being super
duper super strong i don't really care i
think people should be free to do
whatever they want
brother i think in order to stay highly
competitive especially on the west coast
it's almost half necessary to start
using stuff because unfortunately to get
to the points that people are displaying
you need help i definitely agree i mean
this is a really touchy subject but with
all the respect for people who are
natural who don't obviously take
anything keep going um the sad truth
about bodybuilding is everyone you're
going against is probably on stuff right
like if you're a bodybuilder how are you
gonna compete otherwise i i totally get
it i'm not judging these people at all i
won that show but the second show i got
destroyed and i realized what time it
was everyone's talking behind stage
about this that if your goal is to be in
that top one percent to make it to the
olympian you're gonna be going against
people who are taking a lot of and i'm
sure if you take a responsibility you
know it's probably not as bad as being
morbidly obese but there's always you
know same as there's being morbidly
obese is really bad for you there's
always going to be the end of people
misusing steroids
likewise as someone who has a addiction
brain you know i can see myself kind of
taking those kind of stuff too far and
it's not so easy for everyone to be
responsible i do completely agree with
all that um and again i compete in the
mpc so that is not drug testing national
committee a few spots away from my pro
card at nationals a few times being
completely natural
and i'm not against taking drugs
she's such a boastful annoying person
everyone is like typing her in that chat
i don't get it man what did i mention
that i competed like okay that was not
the question for me i just never thought
about doing that because of like the
long term consequences that it may bring
if not accompanied uh by like a doctor
oh look at that more like a professional
so i just wanted to like stay natural
oh but like if you're doing it in a
healthy and safe way then
you do you i guess
this guy's me trying to walk this thin
line of uh people want to do sirens they
can do it but i just don't personally
want to
when i remember i wanted to be bigger
and i was thinking in my head like i
could not freaking wait to find me
a drug dealer so i can get on some
steroids you don't have to worry about
asking you don't have to worry about
spreading rumors because i am definitely
100 on something it's not abuse
no i appreciate you being honest about
it even though it is kind of obvious but
uh i don't understand why everyone wants
to be huge i don't get it the greeks
discover the ideal body we already know
what to aspire for it's not these
ginormous monstrous looking people right
it's not something you need steroids to
necessarily achieve right and plus i
know i'm not as strong as this i
generally don't care and and like this
is probably something what i would
strive towards this kind of body shape
uh but if i'm not i generally don't care
because i'm working out because i enjoy
it it makes me feel good it's a great
routine that i enjoy and i it removes
that anxiety for me of feeling like oh
i'm not
that enough it's like no well i'm
working my way towards it
all right what else can i do i don't get
it i guess maybe maybe then while i'm
this age you know you can ask me hey are
you strong enough and we'll see
i just i just know what i want out of it
so it's not like something where you end
up having this situation where you have
right rage or you have someone who's
angry all the time a person is an
[ __ ] they're an [ __ ] it has
nothing to do with what they take so
just being real
but it is the it is the symptom that you
do
that a lot of people do get
you're
that isn't
sure acting upon it it doesn't allow it
but i mean it's still a thing come on i
respect you being so transparent about
it because a lot of them just try to say
oh i'm natural like i did this and you
can do this too and it's just like
no like why are you afraid if you take
peds then just say that you do i don't i
don't understand the whole yeah i
actually agree with her on this it's i
don't think it's that
simple so much high pressure and
standard on people being a certain way
in everything everything is so
competitive not just being working out
of course people are going to cheat and
lie about it of course what do you mean
don't understand why
oh this is interesting okay
absolutely
oh damn
that's great
literally everyone agrees yeah i think i
can have a day but then i get a workout
and it completely resets your mind and
your mood it's like a weird meditation
practice almost i would say it's
something that everyone should do not
necessarily you know any form of
exercise if you're feeling down i think
starting to exercise is the first step
you could take it also changes your mind
and how you perceive things because
you're starting to build yourself and
improving yourself and that i think that
changes how you think in in many
positive ways it made me like forget my
problems and just like focus all my rage
and anger towards like hitting new pr's
and stuff
so
yeah thank you bodybuilding definitely
can be a mental relief to you you know
that's your only you time where you
really get to have when you're going to
train right you learn your self-worth
exactly exactly definitely because it's
you versus you at the end of the day
that's how the sport is right it's a
selfish sport but it helps you mentally
it builds you up for sure most important
thing to me
no
no no no
my body and soul
okay you gotta work on both equally
important all right i guess the thing
with like philosophy
where i like to combine my ideas with
why i work out and building not just my
body but my mind as well i see it as a
as a
very deeply connected process
surprised how split it is on this
i really feel like
i mean they're bodybuilders you're
asking bodybuilders obviously it's
important to them it's their job i think
it's different and i think a lot of it
goes with this i think there's this
gonna be a disconnect with what i say
and there and say and it's not
necessarily fair because they're in a
different ballpark than me and i
acknowledge that obviously my family and
god come first and then there's my body
but especially if it's your dream to
make it to the top and everything well
then it's not the most important thing
you just answered it it is your
investment that you got to take care of
constantly right yeah
one-on-one season one competition that's
my borrowed time for myself at six
months i'm being the most selfish that i
can you know i'm not going anywhere i'm
not doing anything like eating out but
once i'm out of prep then yeah
everything else comes first
sometimes those things take a precedent
if i'm in prep i'm sorry like i'm not
answering the phone but if i'm out of
prep and a friend calls and i was
supposed to get a workout in that day
looks like i'm not going to the gym she
needs me oh
god damn how about that they all turn
out to be very uninteresting
i guess the thing what i meant is like
how working out starts changing your
mind and and wanting to improve and i
think i don't know i'm surprised that
none of them sort of talk about it my
body is my temple
and like nothing feels better
than being in shape well what do you do
when you lose your shape by an accident
or you lose an arm or i don't know like
you said what if something happens that
makes it so you don't
cannot work out anymore you're locked in
your body then you're going to be
immediately unhealthy and you're not
mentally prepared for that
you're sort of limiting and trapping
yourself if you put that much emphasis
on your body i love working out i love
improving proving myself but you're
you're building up something i think
toxic if you yeah put that much emphasis
on it that's just my opinion that's just
some ideas random thoughts what do you
think i'm curious
let me know and see you in tomorrow
video subscribe for more uh videos i
really enjoy these type of stuff where
we can have a discussion epic and uh
yeah see you tomorrow profess